all right Ian is with us in San Jose
California hey Ian what's up man hey
Dave it's a pleasure to talk to you you
too
how can I help um so I finished baby
step two last month and I'm cranking
away at baby step 3 so I'm looking
forward to baby step 4
so you recommend 15% month toward
retirement while paying off your house
well I I rent right now so I don't have
a house payment okay um so I but I I was
wondering you know what if I put 40
percent of my income and toward
retirement um then I could retire
instead of at 65 maybe at 40 I'd be
pretty cool why don't we set up and pay
cash for our house first because I'm not
necessarily as interested in owning a
house right now at least for a long time
at least um how long um hey I'm I'm not
necessarily interested in ever owning a
house right now it Y is you because it's
a lot of work just the maintenance and
the unexpected costs that come from it
yeah and how old are you I'm 27 okay you
might talk to people about what rent
cost when you were born versus what rent
costs now okay and were you to own a
house you wouldn't have that increase
because I'm 56 and what you could rent
for five hundred bucks when I was your
age is now 2000 right and that's going
to happen to you and it's going to steal
your wealth and the beauty one of the
beauties of owning your residence
especially out right is as a long-term
wealth building tool a it goes up in
value and B you stabilize your cost of
housing which otherwise is going to ramp
ramp up on a curve that's going to make
you lose your lunch right that's not
from a stent long term standpoint I get
that it's a lot of work and I'm not sera
saying you cut grass to get you a condo
care right on I'm with you on that I'm
much cutting grass I kind of grass
Pathan I was 18 God said I never had to
do it again so yeah but I'm with you but
but and I don't want climb up on the
ladder and do the painting either I've
done that and fell off a ladder a couple
times because I'm not smart and so you
just don't I get that you don't want all
that so but let's look at the financial
implications of a lifelong plan of not
owning your own residence that wouldn't
be wise but I love that you're able to
keep your personal overhead so low that
you can discuss 40 percent of your
income going to anything that makes you
a rock star so you got a lot of choices
dude but that way I would just challenge
your philosophy on that basis and give
you something to think about
and so having said that my personal goal
if I'm the way answer questions again is
if I was 27 and knew what I knew now
what would I do if I were in your
situation I would say 15 percent of my
income and throw the other 25 percent in
a bucket and pay cash for a nice little
condo and soon as I did that I kick it
up to 40 percent now I got zero cost for
rent
for the rest of my life because this is
paid for except for the HOA and you know
the insurance which is always going to
be built into your rent anyway so um you
know and then you can really save and
become a multi bazillionaire and live
like no one else and give like no one
else and so your long-term goals still
there we're just going to stabilize your
housing costs as a part of the plan
that's the only I guess tune up to your
idea I would bring hey thanks for the
call this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you